>>Scott: Hi guys.
>>Scott: I was a student that
probably could have fallen
through the cracks pretty easily and
I always vowed that if I was ever
into education I was going to create
a school in which all kids counted
and that we did everything
in our power for kids.
>>How are you?
>>Mom: Good how are you?
Come on, kids!
>>Scott: Look at you go, Girl!
>>Mom: I know, we're workin' it!
>>Scott: There is no stopping you!
>>I just really believe that
more than ever before we need
to teach kids the skills of
self-regulating their emotions.
We know that they're going
to benefit from dealing
with social-emotional components.
They're going to perform
academically and they're going
to perform very strongly.
>>Rebecca: The social-emotional
learning allows me to be a teacher.
The students are motivated to learn
and to have that leadership role
within the classroom
to have that sense
of community and a sense of family.
>>I would like someone to choose
how we're going to transition
from our desks to the rug.
Emeris?
>>Emeris: Thumb walk.
>>Rebecca: Thumb walk?
And can you tell the
class your expectations?
>>Emeris: Quiet and don't talk.
>>Rebecca: One of the
things that's crucial
with a Responsive Classroom
is allowing the kids
to take the leadership role.
They made a list of how they
would like to transition
from one activity to the next.
Doing a thumb walk
where they walk slowly
and basically twiddle their thumbs.
>>Julian: The transitions
make me feel relaxed
and they help me calm down.
>>Rebecca: We are going
to start morning meeting
with what we did this weekend.
I know a lot of you had
some great stories to share
so we will start with Jacob.
>>Jacob: I saw the ice boats just
fly and that was really, really cool.
>>Elizabeth: When people share
things I always get a little picture
in my mind of what they're doing.
>>Rebecca: This is our family time.
We come together as a family and from
here we talk about any successes,
accomplishments students have had,
and it just sets us up for the day.
>>We are going to do yoga
this morning and we are going
to transition from the
rug down to the forum.
When you're ready you may
start your stretch walk.
>>Usually every day try
to do some type of yoga,
whether it's just a
couple of minutes a day
or twice a week I do a full
blown 40-minute yoga class.
>>Elizabeth: The yoga and the
transitions, it's helping me also
when I'm at home I'm also
calming down more too.
>>Rebecca: This is something that
I can't start my day without.
Oftentimes with kids
they don't realize
that their body will tell them
how they are feeling before their
brain does.
With yoga we get that out of
them and it's a way for them
to release all their energy,
get them ripe for learning.
>>How do you think that doing yoga
in the morning especially
before writing is helping us?
>>Jacob: I feel much more
relaxed and more focused.
>>Student: All the yoga that we
do helps us do more writing time
in the small amount of time we have.
>>Rebecca: The advice that I would
give to a teacher about wanting
to implement social-emotional
learning
into their classroom
is that it's easy.
It's easy and it's something that
comes natural to all teachers.
It's incorporating the
movement, incorporating a voice
for our students, incorporating that
community, that sense of family.
>>Scott: Once you have a culture
where staff are committed to kids,
it spreads like wildfire.
All of the things that we do
have been teacher-initiated.
I'm smart enough to
know as the leader
of my school is I'm not the expert.
My teachers are the experts.
A key mindset I think is for
leaders of schools to feel empowered
to give their teachers a license
to do these types of things.